someone wrote me a note says bobo
bleached his goatee the same way as
guy fieri are you into guy fieri bobo
you dyed your beard
no no no no i do my own thing alex
i want to look like a billy goat let me
take a look i need to see this oh
that is disturbing wow oh my god
wow who's like are you grooming that
yourself
yeah oh my god it's wild
the street down the middle that uh yeah
that's what that is
you dyed part of your beard dark and
left a gray spot
well it's a mustache
it's a different look when you get to
the chin area
there's like a little pubis kind of
gray like a little tiny gray
patch hanging down now that i have my
shaved head i got you know
i tried different ways to uh change
things up you know
why i don't know just experiment
different looks
this is an experiment that went wrong oh
my goodness
i mean imagine the effort that he put
into that i know
let's see how can i look really stupid
today
it would look better if he didn't like
have that whole
patch going from the bottom of his lip
all the way down to his chin
if he had like a little like piece under
his lip and that would be it
it would look probably it shouldn't be
connected is what you're saying it just
should be yeah
don't you think a woman sees that and
goes wow look how weird that is that
guy's spending like
a tremendous amount an inordinate amount
of time on his facial hair
like does he think he looks hot the guys
in the back are all saying
it is very clear that bobo ripped off
this guy fieri uh like it's no
way that he it's not you know he's not
original yeah but guy fieri's is even
thicker than it you know yeah yeah he's
got
right yeah his is a lot different it's
not pencil thin
right well that's his individuality i
think no that's why he says he's doing
his own thing i guess
yeah to me that beard that bobo just
grew is like
a guy who's very concerned about his
appearance but he's making all the wrong
choices
that patch looks like it belongs on a
guy who regularly [ __ ] a vacuum cleaner
and he is a guy who [ __ ] a vacuum
cleaner